sci-fi shows that didn't live up to
expectations were often
unceremoniously canceled in the 90s
usually for
complicated fascinating and bizarre
reasons
here's why some sci-fi classics near
classics and never got to be classics
had their runs cut short even today the
concept of quantum leap is pretty novel
offering up endless possibilities for a
sci-fi show
dr sam beckett develops time travel
technology and tests it on himself
traveling into the past and temporarily
appearing as a different person in each
episode
oh boy after some humorous growing pains
as sam gets used to his new identity he
ultimately rolls with it and invariably
leaves his momentary host's life a
little bit better than before he arrived
and his guide through it all is a
present-day-based hologram version of
his friend
al not only one of the few network
sci-fi shows of the time
the 1989-1993 series was the rare genre
show to receive attention from
mainstream awards bodies
quantum leap earned three emmy
nominations for outstanding drama series
while stars scott bakula and dean
stockwell both won a golden globe
but in spite of the acclaim quantum leap
never
leapt to the top of the tv ratings chart
nbc frequently bounced it around
multiple time slots during its four year
run
making it hard for fans to find
viewership numbers reflected that
as the series never ranked higher than
number 53 in the annual ratings
in 1993 nbc cancelled quantum leap
and sam never even made it home
it's only recently that superhero based
series have become mainstream
entertainment worthy of huge budgets and
good time slots
in fall 2019 half the cw's 12 prime
time shows were based on dc comics
characters one that's been consistently
popular since its debut is the flash
which stars grant gustin as barry allen
aka the title character who wears a red
jumpsuit and can run preposterously fast
however
it's actually the second network
primetime show about the speedster
following cbs's 1990 series the flash
starring john wesley's ship as the
world's quickest hero
a dark moody crime heavy show cbs had a
lot of faith in the series
dropping a whopping 6 million bucks on
the pilot episode alone
including 100 000 on ship's flash
costume
so uh what am i wearing here
cbs didn't play it safe with the
scheduling though placing the flash a
60-minute show in a bizarre
hour straddling time slot of 8 30 to 9
30 p.m
opposite nbc's mega hits a different
world in cheers
as well as fox's hot soap beverly hills
90210
too few people watched such an expensive
show and cbs stopped it
after its one and only season
the early 90s nbc series seaquest dsv
had all the makings of a hit
after all the show was set on a
high-tech deep sea vessel staffed by
genius scientists portrayed by the likes
of jaws star
roy scheider and teen heartthrob of the
moment jonathan brandis as they had
exciting action-packed sci-fi adventures
the crew
also interacted with a talking dolphin
named darwin and met a mermaid
a joint production of universal studios
in steven spielberg's amblin television
it boasted a huge per episode budget
that made for
great for tv at the time special effects
and yet nbc couldn't pull in a big
audience for its freshman season
seaquest dsv ranked a lowly number 83 in
the ratings perhaps because it aired
opposite cbs is very popular
murder she wrote and fox's martin
efforts to revamp the series switching
out cast members committing to
less science-heavy stories and venturing
outside of the submarine more often
only worked a little with the show
moving up to 64th place in the ratings
for the 1994-1995 season
for season three producers once more
made broad changes
moving the action ahead ten years
dumping schneider in favor of michael
ironside as a new captain
and renaming the show seaquest 2032
that didn't do the trick as the show
fell to a lowly number 117 before nbc
permanently sank the series
anchoring nickelodeon's saturday night
snick lineup for most of the mid 90s
the secret world of alex mack was a
sci-fi show about an arizona teenager
who gets covered in a secret proprietary
chemical that gives her powers like
telekinesis
the ability to shoot electricity out of
her fingertips and to transform into a
sentient
puddle at will one minute i'm walking
home the next there's a crash and i'm
drenched in some weird chemical
the powers were difficult to control and
often arbitrary making the secret world
of alex mack a sci-fi allegory about the
constantly baffling weirdness of
adolescence
alex mack ran on nickelodeon from 1994
to 1998 and the network was more than
willing to green light a fifth season
executive producer and co-creator tommy
lynch took star larissa
olenek along with her mother and manager
out to a fancy dinner at a hollywood
restaurant
there he formally presented his offer
for season five which also included a
substantial amount of money
and a proposal of an alex maca movie
however olenek said no thanks
the actress told huffpost it was an
incredible thing he was offering me
and i knew that at the time but i was a
little burnout
she wanted to finish high school and
attend college and also leave the alex
mac character where she was at with the
conclusion of season four
as elenic explained she was starting to
grow up in that last season
she gets a boyfriend i just kind of
wanted to keep it innocent
babylon 5 was among the most prominent
sci-fi shows of the 90s
its first four seasons aired on local tv
stations affiliated with the primetime
entertainment network programming block
and when that conglomeration went
defunct the show finished its run
on cable network tnt babylon 5 ran for
five
seasons as had been the intent from the
beginning for creator j
michael strzinski he'd mapped out one
big grand story about a space station
its inhabitants and the sometimes
warring alien races it encounters
in 1999 about a year and a half after
the final babylon 5 aired
tnt broadcast a call to arms a babylon 5
made for tv movie that acted as a bridge
and set up to a new space set series
called
crusade an entire first season of 13
episodes were written
shot and completed only for tnt to
preemptively
cancel crusade before its premiere
rendering the whole thing a limited
series according to strezinski tnt
wanted the show to appeal to a broader
audience
and the studio made him comply with its
creative demands
ultimately strazinski didn't give the
network what it wanted
so it pulled the plug superboy got off
to a rocky start
debuting in syndication in 1988 the show
followed superman aka clark kent
just before he'd grow into his powers as
the man of steel
and find work as a journalist at the
daily planet john haynes newton won the
role of college-age superman but he was
fired after season one when he asked for
more money
could it be because you always have your
greedy paws where they don't belong
that also happened to be around the same
time he arguably violated a morals
clause in his contract
with a public drunkenness arrest
producer ilya salkhind replaced him with
a 31 year old babyfaced baby-faced
model-turned-actor gerard christopher
who proved a good fit
the ratings for the newly rebranded the
adventures of superboy
flew into the list of the 10 most
watched syndicated tv
series a few episodes after his arrival
the adventures of superboy ran for 100
episodes over four
seasons and it was popular enough to
keep going but superman controlling
studio warner brothers wouldn't have it
it started work on a new superman tv
series lois and clark
the new adventures of superman set to
air in prime
time on network television making it a
much more high profile project than the
lowly syndicated superboy
warner not only wouldn't renew the show
but the studio
filed paperwork regarding saulkind's
right to make superman television
preventing even superboy reruns from
airing
in 1993 mighty morphin power rangers
debuted and it quickly became a
multimedia kitty phenomenon
not seen since the likes of masters of
the universe a decade earlier the plot
followed a group
of teenagers who were bestowed with
mystical martial arts abilities
and the control of giant robots which
they used to fight space monsters
mighty morphin power rangers dominated
their ratings while action figures of
the different power rangers flew off the
shelves
a year later the children's television
landscape was flooded with blatant power
rangers clones
including tattooed teenage alien
fighters from beverly hills
superhuman samurai cyber squad and vr
troopers
trooper transform
in that series a group of friends are
given fighting suits and powerful
vehicles by the mysterious professor
heart
who needs them to fight the menacing
army of grim lord which is attempting to
break out of the virtual reality world
and into the meat space unlike the power
rangers the vr
troopers weren't teens but well into
their 20s and unlike the other power
rangers clones
vr troopers lasted two seasons as
opposed to one
what ultimately did it in was that it
couldn't compete with power rangers
where it really counted
toy sales the whole point of vr troopers
was to move toys
and not enough kids bought the
merchandise to justify a third season of
the tv show
if you were a kid tween or non-partying
adult in the early 90s the place to be
on friday nights was in front of the tv
tuned in to abc's tgif lineup of sappy
family-friendly programming like full
house family matters and step by step
by 1996 many tgif shows were fading and
abc made attempts to lure in newer and
even younger viewers with puppet-based
programming and during that season
muppets tonight and aliens in the family
joined tgif
the first was an update of the classic
the muppet show while the latter was a
bizarre sci-fi sitcom about a brady
bunch-esque blended family
except dad doug brody and his kids were
human and
mom cookie and her offspring were mildly
monstrous aliens
their meat cute cookie abducted doug and
then he fell in love with her the show's
real star was the strange and grotesque
bobot a talking baby genius with a taste
for chaos and destruction the creature
even had a catchphrase
i require putting pudding in the morning
well sally doesn't think that's a very
good idea
although the aliens were the work of the
famous jim henson's creature shop the
tonally dissonant aliens in the family
didn't mesh with the rest of tgif
and it lasted just eight episodes nor
did it help to revamp the tgif lineup
which by fall 1996
was back to its lineup of teen centered
shows star trek the next generation
revived and reinvented the star trek
franchise on the small screen
leaving behind the original series is
campy vibe and clunky effects
in favor of sleek high production values
but it also ramped up the thoughtful
meaningful allegorical plots
all led by the captivating patrick
stewart as the kind and brave captain
jean-luc picard
after seven successful seasons the next
generation wrapped up with a finale
episode that drew more than 31
million viewers blockbuster ratings for
a network tv show but unheard of for a
series syndicated to individual local
stations
a few months later the show received an
emmy nomination for outstanding drama
series which was an extreme
rarity for a non-network show and a
sci-fi series
so why would paramount set phasers to
cancel the big screen
beckon just four days after the last
episode of the next generation wrapped
cast members reported to a different
stage on the paramount lot to film star
trek
generations the first movie in the
long-running blockbuster franchise to
feature the casts of both
flagship star trek shows in that film
the old crew
passed the torch to the newer one
william shatner's captain kirk died
making room for picard and company to
occupy three more star trek movies
with the commercial and critical
popularity of star trek the next
generation
it was clear that 90s tv viewers wanted
more science fiction options
particularly star trek shows in 1993
the space station set star trek deep
space nine debuted in syndication
featuring avery brooks as commanding
officer benjamin cisco the first
african-american lead character in
franchise history
i can assure you this old cat may not be
as toothless as you think
right now i've got 5 000 photon
torpedoes armed and ready to launch
ds9 earns solid ratings and syndication
for most of its early seasons
guaranteeing at least a moderately long
run the success of fox in the late 80s
and early 90s showed the tv industry
that there was room on the dial beyond
the big three
of abc cbs and nbc in 1993
plans for new channels upn and wb were
underway the new networks competed to
nail down affiliates most of which were
formerly independent channels around the
us
and which had relied heavily on
syndicated programming like deep space
nine
in short order a few hundred formerly
independent stations signed up to air
upn
and wb programming and non-network shows
suddenly had less access to air time
oddly enough upn was operated by
paramount the rights holder of star trek
properties the very first show ever
broadcast on upn
voyager another star trek series don't
let them do
anything that takes you off the bridge
of that ship because while you're there
you can make a difference check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite sci-fi shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one